[Music]
hey you guys time once again for another
book review
this is another novel that i just
randomly came across while i was you
know scrolling through all the offerings
on the kindle unlimited you know the
free selections
and i don't know what it was about this
particular book that kind of like caught
my eye um i guess like the cover and the
title sounded kind of like mysterious i
wasn't even really sure what it was
about but i was kind of like ah why not
i'll give that a whirl now i actually
checked this book out
probably like a month or two ago and
because if you have kindle unlimited you
can check out like 10 books at once and
so i checked it out i think la and i was
going to read it last month and then it
got pushed back because somebody sent me
one and all this other stuff so i didn't
get around to reading it so i was like
oh yeah maybe i should do that because
it's been out for a couple months and
i'm glad i finally got around to reading
this one because i and ended up enjoying
this one quite a bit so this is a book
that came out back in i believe
september of 2020 and it's called
gilchrist by christian gallacher
now i looked up the author bio and
apparently this is kind of cool this guy
um i guess he got a degree in finance
and worked in that field for some time
but i guess he'd always kind of like had
aspirations to be a fiction writer to
his horror fiction specifically and so
in 2012 he actually started writing and
publishing uh his own novels now this is
the first one of his that i've read i
think he's read he's written a couple
more since then now one thing i will say
the guy is like he he says in his bio
that one of his biggest influences is
stephen king
now when you first start reading this
book that will become very apparent this
is a very stephen king-like book
uh specifically it reminded me a great
deal of it it reminded me a great deal
of a little bit of the tommy knockers
that type of thing it's like a cursed
town type situation now some reviews of
it that i read were just kind of like
nah i'm not having it it's you know it's
too much like stephen king
and they couldn't really uh they weren't
really down with it i didn't find that
it is stephen king like but not so much
that i thought he was like ripping him
off or it was just like a pastiche or
anything like that so
i mean if you're a fan of this stephen
king's kind of like big sprawling sorts
of novels that are kind of all set like
around one town like maybe under the
dome or something like that um then this
would probably be right up your alley
now it doesn't wasn't just stephen king
that this gave me vibes of i also got a
little bit of dean coons from it got a
little bit of robert mccammon in there
as well in the sense that particularly
something like boys life that's just
kind of like about uh this town and it's
kind of like all these characters like
in this town so i kind of got that vibe
from it as well
but yeah it's like i yes it is stephen
king but
not to a degree that it bothered me and
actually i really ended up liking this
book a lot and after i finished it and
[ __ ] i started reading it one day and i
read for like an hour or something i was
like okay i gotta stop and go do
something else but then like the next
day i read the whole rest of the book
and it's pretty long it's like over 500
pages so i basically just sat like one
afternoon and like read the whole like
uh thing because i got really really uh
into it so what is this book about
so this book is set
back in 1966
near concord massachusetts
now at the first the first part of the
book we're following a married couple
peter and sylvia martell
now 18 months two years prior to the
events of the story uh they have lost
their little boy noah who i think was
two or three years old in a horrible
accident like he fell out a window like
when they weren't watching him or
something like that
so obviously they're still uh grieving
from that and you know things have
started to fall apart a little bit it's
not like disastrous or anything but you
know they've been kind of drinking too
much um sylvia is kind of like you know
hitting the pills a little hard and you
know they're not really connecting the
way they used to you know everything's
just sort of a shadow of what it used to
be
now they have been trying to have
another child because they think that
you know that will maybe go some way
toward mending the rift i guess
uh but for about 18 months they've been
having a really hard time not being able
to conceive so they've gone to a
fertility doctor you know it's near the
beginning of the story to see if
something is physically wrong now the
doctor says nothing's physically wrong
with either one of you so it could be
psychological it could be something that
we don't know what it is so it's like
well you know all you can do is just
keep trying now sylvia didn't really
want to hear this um she's already kind
of depressed like i said not
surprisingly
uh and this kind of like ambiguity this
lack of a reason she's like i almost
would have felt better if they just said
hey one of us is infertile or something
because at least then we would know um
but just kind of this ambiguity is
really bothering her so she kind of like
gets starts getting more and more
depressed
so they have all of that going on
now peter is actually a novelist he's
not a horror novelist he's more kind of
like a literary novelist and is you know
apparently pretty successful at it like
he's kind of well known
now he seems to have not too long after
this fertility doctor thing happens he
has this really really weird dream one
night uh it involves kind of like
there's like a red sky and there's like
a weird [ __ ] up looking church and
like these kind of like wormy things and
then this kind of like being with this
really weird like face whose
colors shifting face and all this other
stuff kind of stuff now in this dream oh
and i think he also sees himself like as
an old person like in a reflection or
something
so it's just like this really really
creepy dream that he has and it makes
like makes like a big impact during the
course of this dream he hears a voice
and if it's a voice he doesn't recognize
saying the word gilchrist now he does
not know what this is but like i said
the dream kind of sticks with him
because it's pretty creepy
not too long after this though uh he's
driven to another town i think he was at
his publishers or something like that
and he was driving back to i think they
live in concord massachusetts so he's
driving back to concord on a route that
he's taken many many times before
but today he suddenly sees like a road
sign you know that has all the cities
that says concord this exit you know
worcester this exit whatever but he's
like he notices that sign says gilchrist
on it and has an exit for that he's like
well that's really funny i never noticed
that before um he's like but you know
it's it's a road that he takes all the
time maybe he just takes the signs for
granted because he always knows where
he's going and he's not really looking
at it and he thinks oh well maybe that's
why i dreamed that because i kind of
like saw it
and it kind of like came up in my
subconscious or whatever
but he's curious enough about
this gilchrist place and because it was
in his dream he's like you know i i got
a little bit of time i'm gonna like pop
down to that town and see what the
[ __ ] going on you know what i mean
just uh just out of curiosity
so he goes down to this town and it's
like i said it's a pretty small town
a little downtown there uh you know like
i said it's 1966 so it's a little main
street or whatever not a lot of people
around uh but he's like man i'm you know
i'm kind of hungry i'll just like stop
it and get something to eat or get a
beer or something like that so he goes
to this tavern
and when he's on his way into the tavern
like this guy comes out who is clearly
very inebriated
and says like something really weird to
him and then like licks his face and so
he's just kind of like okay
uh but then the guy that owns the tavern
whose name is george comes out it's like
oh you know he's
just you know it's he's it's it's a
whole thing it's like he's harmless it's
fine sorry about that um you know come
in and i'll make you some food or
whatever so he gives him like some
burgers and stuff and he's super super
nice
and peter is just kind of like man this
town it's like i feel like i've been
here before even though i absolutely
know i have not
but there's something about it that's
really really attractive to him it's
just like not like there's this whole
like i said this whole deja vu about it
there's like a whole nostalgic type of
he's like there's even like a nostalgic
scent to it it almost smells like smoky
like autumn and he's like i really and
i'm really really into it so kind of on
a whim he says you know uh since me and
sylvia have been having so many problems
and maybe it'd be good for us to get
away for a little while i'm gonna rent a
vacation house like a vacation cabin
just for three weeks or something like
that so we can get away and it'll be
like a fresh start and everything
so he goes down to the realtor's office
and the realtor i think his name is leo
is also super friendly and he's like
matter of fact he's like i have like a
really good cabin that normally would be
rented by this time of summer but you
know you lucked out nobody's running it
for this particular three weeks and it's
this little cabin and it's called shady
cove
and it's right on the edge of this uh
lake that all the locals call big bath
and he shows him pictures and he's like
that looks absolutely perfect it's very
very quiet and secluded and he said you
know matter of fact two years ago uh
there was another writer who stayed
there named declan wade who was a horror
writer and uh peter's like yeah i know
who the [ __ ] that is he's like really
famous
and he's like yeah he stayed there and
he wrote a novel like you know he wrote
one of his best-selling novels in that
very cabin so he's like well gosh it
sounds like kismet
so he basically he doesn't even go out
to see the place he just sees the
pictures and you know leo seems very
nice so he's just kind of like okay so
he signs the rental agreement
so he goes back home uh to tell sylvia
that he rented a cabin and that they're
gonna do like a vacation for three weeks
uh but when he gets there and like i
said i don't want to spoil too much
about this because um this like i said
it's kind of better if you don't really
see where it's going
but
when he gets back home uh something bad
has happened and
it kind of goes from there now
interestingly and i will admit that at
this point in the story this was a
little bit jarring for me so
do know that this book much like some of
stephen king's books like i said that
are kind of set around
you know around dairy maine or something
like that that are kind of these big
sprawling tales about a town
this kind of like shifts back and forth
to a lot of different character
perspectives so the first part of the
book i don't remember how many pages it
is but like the first significant chunk
of the book you're following peter and
sylvia and their whole thing
and then this one bad thing happens when
he comes back from renting the place
like before they even go to the cabin
and then for a long time the perspective
of the story like shifts so it actually
shifts to people in gilchrist like it
shifts to a girl named grace who's like
a high school girl and uh this really
shitty dude named ricky
ricky osterman and you know grace is
kind of like her dad is the police chief
delancey so you know they kind of follow
him as well
so
just know going in that like you know
you get involved with peter and sylvia
but then there's like another like the
following portion of the book is kind of
like more talking about the town of
gilchrist and then it picks back up with
peter and sylvia later on like when they
actually
have resolved what the bad thing that
happened and then they come to the cabin
to do their vacation at which point you
know they start like interacting with uh
the locals and stuff like that yeah so
the thing with this town
it's again it's sort of left a little
bit i don't know if i'd say it's left
ambiguous but
this does have because you know how
in stephen king's it you know you had
pennywise who was kind of some kind of
demon interdimensional being something
like that but his whole thing was you
know he could shape-shift essentially
into like whatever scared you the most
and he usually targeted children and
blah blah so this is kind of like that
but not exactly um the antagonists or
monsters or whatever of gilchrist if you
want to call them that
it's not exactly the same this is kind
of more like
it's kind of more like a cosmic horror
it is kind of like interdimensional as
well they are described but
you're not really entirely sure what
they are i think they're kind of
described at some point as sort of like
vampires more like psychic vampires not
like vampire vampires so it's just kind
of like that but the thing that they do
is that they feed on fear and they feed
on despair
so what they do and like i said this is
a little bit different to how pennywise
operates i feel like although i haven't
read it in a while but i feel like it's
kind of different but the way they
operate in gilchrist is
basically what they'll do is they kind
of get inside people's heads
and
make them do
awful things you know i mean so it's
almost kind of like a little bit of a
possession kind of deal and then when
these awful things happen like all these
tragedies ensue
then they kind of like feed on the um
you know the fear and despair and things
like that that are produced by these
things happening
so and obviously i guess some people are
more susceptible to it than others
that's not really stated outright but i
guess it's kind of like implied you know
so there's that kind of whole thing too
so this is essentially a town that's
cursed basically all that's kind of said
about it is that this is just a place
where it so happens that the
veil or whatever between our world and
the world of these beings whatever it is
they are like i said they're a little
bit cosmic horror lovecraftian type
things so this town is somewhere where
the where the barrier is very thin so
they can kind of like reach across and
like influence people's minds and get
them to do awful things because like i
said gilchrist this is a town where
you know it's mostly a normal town with
normal people but
you know terrible things kind of happen
a little bit more more often than you
would think they would and [ __ ] like
that
so
uh once peter and sylvia get to
gilchrist and start to kind of it's
interesting because when they first get
there it's almost kind of because sylvia
obviously had been having a lot of
problems like before they got there
and when she gets there even though the
town is cursed like i said and there's
these [ __ ] monster things like kind
of lurking around the periphery of the
dimension or whatever
she's actually like much better when she
first gets there like they kind of
rekindle their romance and she's kind of
like much calmer she's gotten over her
grief about the sun dying and she seems
to be like in a much better place but it
seems as though that is maybe part of
the town's allure like it's kind of like
drawing people in like oh you've been
here before oh it's such a nice place or
something like that and like i said it
is a nice place like the people that
live there aren't weird or anything like
that you know they're kind of like
victims just like everyone else is
but i think that's part of the thing
that the monsters kind of have
you know uh kind of set it up so it's
almost like alluring for people so then
they can come in there and then they can
like [ __ ] people up and all kind of like
tragic [ __ ] can happen so that's
essentially what you have going on in
this town it's like a curse town thing
it's beings
who are essentially like cosmic or
interdimensional type beings that feed
on people's despair and so they will
manipulate people into doing things that
cause like massive tragedy and things of
that nature so that's basically what the
story is so like i said it does
it is kind of like a stephen king novel
in that way it's very
sprawling it's basically set
you know in one town and it follows a
bunch of different characters so that's
one thing about this book it's like i
said it's quite long it's over 500 pages
and
you really have to keep track of all
there's not like a [ __ ] ton it's not
kind of like oh there's a new character
being introduced every five seconds or
anything like that but you do have to
realize that
at times there'll be like quite a long
uh extended like chapter or two chapters
about a particular character or set of
characters and then that set of
characters might not come back into the
story until like later on so you do kind
of have to like remember who all of
these people are and what is going on
with all of them um so i kind of feel
like to some of the reviews i read this
seemed to have either like really really
good reviews or like some people were
just like they didn't like it it was too
stephen king or they thought it was too
disjointed
or something like that i didn't find it
disjointed although
as i said you really do have to this
isn't one where you can just kind of
like turn your brain off and read it you
definitely do have to kind of focus it's
not dense or complicated or anything
like that but there are a lot of
characters this is set in one town and
there's a lot of interlocking [ __ ] going
on and there's a lot of things going on
at the same time so you kind of have to
like remember oh yeah that's you know
that's the drunk guy or that's this guy
that had this going on so you do kind of
have to like keep track of a lot of plot
threads if you really want to get into
it and the thing about it was when i was
first reading it to me i was kind of
like at first i was like well it did
seem a little bit disjointed but then
when i finished it and then i thought
about it later
i started realizing that there were kind
of all these connections that i didn't
immediately twig onto when i was reading
it but only kind of like came to light
later i was like oh yeah that character
and this and okay i get it so uh so
maybe i wasn't reading as closely as i
thought i was even though i did read
this pretty closely because i got super
into it and the thing about it is that
you know even though there are a lot of
characters and it jumps back and forth
between them you know the handful that
you do spend the most time with are
really good characters and you really do
like have a lot of sympathy for them um
so when something awful happens to them
and awful stuff happens to a lot of
people in this book the death toll in
this book is very very very high
so uh yeah so this is definitely not a
novel if you want like a happy ending or
like a really like good like big
resolution or something like that the
ending for this one is i don't think i'd
necessarily call it ambiguous because
it's pretty clear what happened but it
is
sort of like the ending it's actually
quite sad and um you know it doesn't get
resolved to any great degree you know
what i mean which makes sense uh with
the kind of horror that this is like i
said this almost struck me as more like
cosmic horror it's kind of like it it's
kind of like the tommy knockers it's not
really aliens but it had that kind of
that similar vibe to it so
if that sounds like something you'd be
into like i said don't go into this like
looking for a happy ending or anything
like that
and keep in mind that you do have to
sort of focus
because it jumps back and forth a lot uh
i will say that there were a couple of
characters in there that i kind of wish
a little bit more had been done with you
know because just there were so many
like the horror writer that i mentioned
earlier declan wade he does actually
show he doesn't literally show up but
there is kind of like a phone
conversation where he like explains some
stuff because he had stayed in that same
cabin so he explains the stuff to peter
and everything like that i kind of wish
that more had been done with him because
he seemed like an interesting character
and also there was this little boy
that was introduced um that was kind of
like a little bit like danny in the
shining like he was kind of like uh he
seemed to have psychic powers and he was
in like a few scenes but i kind of wish
more had been done with that as well but
like i said in the aggregate um yes this
is a lot of characters but the fact that
he was able to like kind of keep them
all straight and keep all the
associations between them straight if
you pay attention then most of the stuff
is like i said i kind of wish there had
been more done with those two characters
in particular but other than that i
really don't have any complaints i got
really really into this book i thought
it was really immersive and i don't know
i just there was something about the
vibe of this that i really liked it had
that like stephen king like 60s
nostalgia small town
creepy type of vibe to it which i like
like i said it was a little bit like
robert mccammon kind of gave me that
sort of vibe as well it was just kind of
this big sprawling all these people all
this like terrible [ __ ] happening and uh
like i said and i kind of like that it
didn't
pull its punches uh you know it didn't
be like oh you like this character this
nobody had plot armor is what i'm saying
it's like so many people [ __ ] die in
this book and in like really really
awful awful ways so i like that it's uh
even though that was kind of a bummer
like in a lot of cases i like that the
book didn't shy away from that i mean he
just like kill air but he didn't kill
everybody but you know we killed a lot
of people he killed a lot of people uh
but yeah so if you like uh stephen king
type stuff that's just kind of like set
in one town and it's like town with a
secret or like there's creepy [ __ ] going
on in the town like i said like it or
the tommy knockers something like that
then you know and you're okay with it
being because like i said i wouldn't
call this a pastiche there's definitely
some homage in there because you know
there's one
there's a couple little characters that
he kind of named and homage to like
stephen king characters and stuff like
that so he's doing it deliberately but
to me that didn't really get in the way
of it i just thought it was like kind of
cute and you know this it is stephen
king but it's not so stephen king that i
was like taken out of it i was still
like really into the story so if that
sounds like something that you would be
into then by all means check it out you
can if you have kindle unlimited you can
actually read it for free or you know
obviously you can just buy the print
book if you would rather do that but
yeah i liked this a lot so if you've
read it or if it sounds interesting to
you then let me know in the comments
what you feel about it and that will do
it for this tomes of terror i will see
you guys on the next one bye